sometimes Dance Moms is more drama than
dancing but that ends when the camera
stopped rolling
usually Jojo C was known for being super
sweet but her claws come out in
defensive Abby Lee Miller some of these
stars just don't get along and Cameron
Bridges claims her experiences on the
show left her with serious PTSD famous
and soon-to-be former Dance Moms star
Abby Lee Miller is a controversial
figure to say the least
I think they need someone in their life
that is tough on them she fully admits
to pushing her students to be the best
they can be
it's just that some fans believe she
pushes them a little bit too far in fact
some of her former students have spoken
out against their former instructor and
made it clear they don't miss working
with her at all one of these former
students is dancer Brooke Hyland who let
her fans know that there's no love lost
between her and Abby Brooke posted a
now-deleted tik-tok video showing that
Facebook had suggested Abby as one of
her potential connections on the app in
response Brooke shook her head and
grimace making it clear this was one
Facebook friend she would not be adding
to her collection Brooke took the clip
down eventually but not before it was
spotted by Joe Josiah who was upset by
her reaction to their former instructor
Jojo commented that it's one thing not
to friend Abby on Facebook but another
to post a video about it Jojo such a
happy cheerful person that her comment
had to hurt it's no secret that Jojo and
Abby are quite close despite Abby's
legal issues and controversies with the
rest of the cast she excused Abby's
angry tirades by saying that she made
the cast of Dance Moms stars and that
the dancers should be grateful for her
help she also revealed that out of the
entire cast of Dance Moms
Abby is the person she keeps in contact
with the most Jojo feels bad that Abby
was hurt by a lot of people and says
she's sad most former Dance Moms stars
don't keep in touch with her anymore
in addition to standing up for Abby when
Brooke openly dismissed her Jojo has
gone out of her way to be there for her
friend when Abby was going through her
battle with cancer Jojo showed up at the
hospital with tons of snacks to share as
well as a $10,000 check from dancers
against cancer it's clear Jojo has
remain
loyal to Abby through the years but the
same can't be said for many of her
fellow dancers friendships often formed
quickly on Dance Moms
and it's not hard to see why these girls
spend long hours working together and
trying to deal with some seriously
stressful situations
Chloe Lucchesi AK and Maddie Ziegler
became fast friends while working
together on the show but unfortunately
they ran into some trouble when it came
to maintaining their friendship both
Maddie and Chloe have been super busy
and admit that they haven't been in
contact as much as they would have liked
Chloe has said that she had lost touch
with her former friend as well as the
rest of the Dance Moms cast
unfortunately we kind of fell out of
touch whenever I left and she left and
we all did our own thing
she said she'd grown apart from Maddie
as well as Brooke Hyland and Niazi AO
due to the fact that they were all
traveling so often I miss Maddie she's
she's really great and I'm really proud
of everything she's doing Chloe claims
competitions never got in the way of
their relationship but the distance
between them has been a lot harder to
look past maddie agrees that their
schedules kept them apart but also added
that things have changed between them
she also confessed to feeling sad about
the loss of their friendship and how
things have changed since her time on
the show meanwhile Maddie has managed to
stay in touch with many of her other
Dance Moms friends including Nia who
says she always has time to stay in
touch with her friends we all know the
moms love to argue amongst themselves on
the show but sometimes the dancers
aren't afraid to speak up when the
issues concern them
when Abby congratulated Kendall vertes
on her performance Ashlee Allen piped up
to point out that she believed her
daughter Brynn had superior dancing
skills Jill vertes fired back that that
was a totally inappropriate conversation
to have in front of their kids but
Ashlee refused to back down eventually
even Kendall spoke up in her own defense
demanding to know why are you so mean
later Kendall said Ashlee's behavior was
totally unacceptable and she's not
afraid to use her voice to call her out
our kids are becoming like their mothers
and is that really a good thing but
Ashlee's daughter Brynn had a different
reaction to Kendall's outburst as she
was reduced to tears over the
like I wish I could scream in her face
and say I mean she is the Kendall
defended her decision to go off on
Ashley now that I'm becoming older and
more mature I have a voice and I'm going
to use it even though Brynn called out
Kendall in defense of her mom ashley was
forced to reflect on her bad behavior
she admitted that she has no issue with
the other moms hating her but seeing
Kendall lose her cool like that was a
lot more difficult although this kind of
drama on the show is unheard of Brynn
didn't let it go when someone made a
crude comment about the team's outfits
on social media Brynn liked the comment
causing some fans to accuse her of being
shady with the exception of Jojo CY it
seems like a lot of her former students
aren't interested in maintaining a
relationship with their former
instructor Abby Lee Miller one of these
students is Maddie Ziegler who became
famous after appearing on the show
during an interview with Us Weekly
Maddie admitted that she doesn't keep in
contact with Abby although she said she
wishes her the best she has no desire to
be part of her life again according to
Abby she felt like a mother figure to
Maddie and her sister Mackenzie and was
devastated when they cut her out of
their lives
Abby wishes she could have been a part
of their massive post-show success and
is disappointed in the way things worked
out between them she claims that without
her hard work and studio time Maddie and
Mackenzie wouldn't be where they are
today during her a significant legal
issues Abby called out her former
students for trying to distance
themselves from her except for Jojo of
course Abby said she's proud of Jojo
firs staying in touch and that pretty
much everyone else might as well have
forgotten her name and it turns out her
star pupil agrees both Maddie and
Mackenzie Oh at least some with her
success to Abby there was a time on
Dance Moms when sisters Paige and Brooke
Hyland were friendly with the rest of
the cast but since they left things
haven't been pretty to say the least we
talked about some of the issues Abby Lee
Miller has with her former students and
how she feels as though they abandoned
her after she helped them with their
careers but things between PA Thailand
and Abby Lee Miller crossed the line
from verbal altercations to a serious
incident during one heated confrontation
between Abby and Paige Abby threw a
chair causing Paige to fear for her own
safety or at least that's what her
lawsuit claimed according to her lawyer
Paige had seen Abby physically engaged
with other members of the cast and was
afraid of things getting worse between
them she filed a five million dollar
lawsuit against Collins Avenue
entertainment for putting her in the
position in the first place and another
suit against Abby for emotional distress
ultimately the emotional distress
charges were dropped but this clearly
didn't improve things between Abby and
Paige no wonder Brooke didn't want to
add her as a friend on Facebook
according to Paige she suffered from
anxiety and panic attacks since her time
on Dance Moms because of her experiences
with Abby
according to Dance Moms star Liliana
catchman she's come up with a great
strategy to deal with all of the mom
drama without letting it affect her
dance routines
I got noise-canceling headphones
whenever the moms have any drama that
involves me I just put on my
noise-canceling headphones and just
focus on the dance even though she
admits it can be stressful whether or
not she can hear them Lilly says she's
motivated by wanting to prove the haters
wrong and show off just how good of a
dancer she really is but while this star
has worked hard to tune out the
over-the-top moms there's one cast
member she has a much harder time not
getting upset by Lilly and Brady Farrar
definitely aren't enemies but she admits
they get on each other's nerves from
time to time she compared their
relationship to that of a brother and
sister and if you have a sibling
yourself you probably know exactly what
that means
according to Lilly Brady can't resist
antagonizing her and no pair of
headphones in existence can tune him out
one of his favorite tricks is taking up
way too much space on the bus when they
travel together and poking her whenever
he can get close enough to do so Eliana
is a dancer who's not afraid to smell
the tea about what it was really like
behind the scenes of Dance Moms she's
the first to admit that some of the
things we saw on television didn't
exactly play out that way behind the
scenes it's highly produced and she
pointed out that something as simple as
an eye roll could be put into a scene to
make it look like a dancer
frustrated with one of their peers
instead of expressing their displeasure
about something else entirely
Eliana says the show stopped short of
handing them scripts but with the right
editing techniques they can change the
narrative to make it seem much more
dramatic and according to Eliana one of
the things the show really wanted to
promote was a supposed feud between her
and fellow Dance Moms star Giannina
apparently it took some time for Eliana
to get the proper permit for appearance
on season 8 although it was just a
paperwork mix-up that's not what it
seemed like on the show cuz they were
both saying that like Giannina like took
me away from everybody while these two
may not be besties both Eliana and
Giannina seem to agree their issues look
way more overblown on the show what do
you think about all of the Dance Moms
drama out there be honest is it why you
tuned into the show or do you just love
watching the competitions share your
thoughts on this situation with us and
your fellow Dance Moms fans in the
comments section below and don't forget
to click subscribe for more videos from
us here at the things thanks for
watching we'll see you again next time